Attorney General William bar will be on
Capitol Hill this morning in his first
major public appearance since he
received the special counsels report
from Robert Muller last month Barr is
scheduled to testify about next year's
budget request for the Justice
Department the Russia investigation is
also expected to come up Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy this should be
interesting to watch it should be
because if you look at bars written
testimony prepared in advance he doesn't
plan to bring up the Muller report at
all today but Democrats are sure to ask
him about it and especially about those
reports that he may have
mischaracterized some of the reports
findings they are also going to want to
know when he plans to release the four
hundred page report and how many
redactions he plans to make to it
they've been threatening to subpoena the
entire thing for a couple of weeks now
New York's Nita Lowey whose chairs this
House Appropriations Committee is going
to tell Barr that his handling of the
Muller report so far has been quote
unacceptable and that his four-page
letter about the report is quote more
suspicious than impressive now Barr has
been promising to hand over the redacted
version by mid April which is obviously
coming right up he's going to be grilled
about that self-imposed deadline here in
the House today and then in the Senate
tomorrow will be fascinating to watch
Nancy thank you so much